I want people to get to a place of I
choose to only eat meat not I can only
eat meat my real thing is if you heal
with this you can help so many people
heal that don't realize they're sick and
that's like part of the reason I'm still
looking and it happened looking is
because there's so many people that
follow me and I'm like the idea with the
diet is you use this and then you
reintroduce Foods there's so many people
who can't read especially people who
gravitate towards a lion diet those are
the people yeah do that diet that can't
reintroduce foods and it's like wow
something's obviously wrong you should
be able to
[Music]
Judy Cho welcome to my podcast thank you
for having me
I'm very excited about this episode I've
been wanting to talk to you for a while
I got your book the carnivore here when
it came out and it's probably the only
book that I've read that made sense to
me and they didn't have any like
carnivore ideology in it it's like
people are only you know I mean I like I
I agree that people should be focused on
an animal-based diet and that's how
people should eat but it wasn't like
people are carnivores and we should be
eating this way and it was just focused
on healing and health right and so I've
been wanting to get you on the podcast
for a while because you're one of the
only people I follow in the carnivore
community that I think is focused on
healing and finding root causes and not
not in like ideological at all so thank
you
yeah so I guess before we get started
can you give a brief background about
who you are and what it is you do sure
so I'm Judy Cho also known as nutrition
with Judy I am board certified in
holistic nutrition my journey with
carnivore really started because I got
sick I was a Management Consultant for
12 years plant-based for 12 years as
well and then all of a sudden I was
struggling with depression I got on
antidepressants and eventually gone on
antipsychotics for getting really really
sick
and never once did anyone say that my
plant-based diet was not ideal for me so
um I basically had a breakdown and I my
oldest son was six months old something
happened I took antibiotics I don't
really know what the mechanistic reason
was I landed in the mental hospital
because I was just oh acting off and
they put they got me on antipsychotics
antidepressants and again they never
figured out what was wrong they just
said I think she's suffering from
bulimia and an eating disorder and then
maybe postpartum depression even though
it was six months after having a baby
and so they said she should go to an
eating disorder facility So I listened I
did all the things they recommended
because I just wanted a normal life and
to have my son back and so I went my son
stayed with my parents in Los Angeles
and then I went back to Austin Texas uh
checked myself into an eating disorder
facility they taught me lots of good
mental health supports finding the
purpose of like what's what drives me
and things like that but the diet was
still very very standard American diet
they would give us microwave pizzas and
such and said if you yeah feel triggered
you're still disordered and I found the
keto diet I found the carnivore diet and
basically essentially until I found
carnivore and I was so desperate because
I was so sick I never fully healed I
once I hit carnivore I was able to get
off all my meds I don't have a day of
depression I've been carnivore for over
five years now and and then I realized
that our diet and our recommendations
were so wrong and I'm such an
inquisitive person that I needed to
figure out why and so when I was on
medical disability for my mental illness
and breakdown I just started researching
all this stuff about food and nutrition
and biochemistry and I got mad and so I
I quit my job I went back to nutritional
therapy school and and then I just
started advocating I learned so much
about how to make presentations for CEOs
and making a case and that's what I now
do for a carnivore diet and it's not
just about this is Dogma this is you
know we're a Bro Science or bro diet I
don't believe in that it's just I want
people to heal and if I need to prove
the science to you so that you can heal
using this diet then by all means I will
do that
hey guys if you enjoy a few glasses of
wine once a week or a drink at any point
in your life in any amount you need to
try the supplement I launched after
party it helps you break down a sea
towel to hide which is the toxin that
alcohol ethanol converts into in your
body when you drink that poisons you and
leads to alcohol damage the supplement
is made of dihydromyrocitin
which is a terrible name for a
supplement which is why we called it
after party which also works weekly on
Gaba so it can help with anxiety
following drinking as well if that's
something that bugs you obviously don't
abuse alcohol but if you're into
biohacking and you don't have a hangover
pill you're doing it wrong you could say
you're doing biohacking wrong if you
drink anything but hey Life Is Life
sometimes people want to have a few
drinks
smartdrugs.life code MP for 15 off and
you can try it for 30 days completely
risk-free because we'll give you your
money back if you don't want it
obviously there's no point in getting
wasted so don't do that but there's also
no point in drinking any amount
without helping your body break down
acetaldehyde so try it out
smartdrugs.life code MP for 15 off I
hope you enjoy the rest of this episode
that's brutal did you have um did you
have a hard time getting off of the
medications you were on
I honestly lost my memory so I have no
idea
um oh yeah it was really I mean I get
really emotional still thinking about it
um I was breastfeeding and and then I
was in the medical or the mental
hospital and I was on a mandatory hold
meaning that they thought they
determined I was a harm to myself and so
I was on a lockdown for 72 hours and so
I was forced to stop nursing and the
class C Drugs of the anthem oh yeah so
the class C Drugs
um you're not allowed a nurse I didn't
know any of this so but my memory would
be and I would hear from my best friend
that would come visit me I'd ask where's
Caleb
um I need to nurse him and they would
have to keep going through and telling
me you'd no longer nurse and then I
would ask why and then I would start
crying and not knowing that I'm going
through the same thing for three days in
a row and then
and I was plant-based then so that my
husband didn't know what to do so
started my child on soy milk breast milk
or formula and it was just a hard
process for all of us and it's um I I
don't know
the medication it didn't really work for
me at least the antidepressant side of
it I was on I listened to them for the
next three months I um I took the full
dose and then it wasn't working enough
that I went on 300 milligrams which is
the highest dose back then for that
specific SSRI and it wasn't working
enough and that's when
um they recommended the antipsychotic to
add to it but it was starting to make me
gain weight and suffering from an eating
disorder I was not okay with that so it
was just this constant back and forth of
struggling with mental illness but I
didn't feel any after effects of getting
off it because I one I lost my memory
when I did the antipsychotics but then
um it just didn't work for me as well
yeah yeah okay okay well that's awful
that is awful it's no wonder you still
get emotional talking about that I still
get emotional talking about like bad
things like that because it's so bad
it's hard to describe how bad that is so
I can understand why you've gone in the
direction you've gone in try to make
people better and teach people about the
carnivore diet yeah yeah yeah crazy
um but what I wanted to I mean I have a
bunch of questions for you that I think
will help
people who are new to the diet and then
I have a bunch of questions that I'm
just curious about because I as you know
I've been on the carnivore diet
specifically like Lion diet or ruminant
meat
um for five years and my assumption
getting onto the diet was once I became
asymptomatic was
I'll slowly be able to reintroduce Foods
right like there's some sort of gut
healing that takes place and I will
slowly be able to reintroduce foods but
that hasn't happened for me and I've
tried a number of different times and I
can't do it so I still have crazy
inflammatory responses now they're not
like like before diet or when I first
started they were so bad that like it
would me for like a month
and now it's not like that like
um so in that way it's gotten better but
there's still something missing yes and
recently like um about two years ago I
think I I realized I had histamine
intolerance and I didn't know what that
was before I figured out what that was
and recently I started taking this
enzyme which has made an insane insane
difference and my mom was the person who
actually found it and it's the Dao
enzyme and I was like scared of taking
it because it's derived from poor sign
kidney and I can eat pork okay so I was
like no I'm not taking any supplements
but I started taking this enzyme and it
now I can eat you know
kind of aged meat without having any
digestive upset or anything so that's
huge and so now I'm thinking
I'm I just feel like there's something
I'm missing whether it's like a
probiotic I can tolerate or enzymes that
I'm missing or something to reduce the
inflammatory response yeah and then I
heard you talk about sirs so I kind of
brought you on to talk about that yeah
yeah so just to give you context of the
people I work with we have a private
practice we focus on root cause healing
we use the carnival cares all meat
Elimination Diet similar to The Lion
diet when you start at Baseline and what
we found over the years is that
carnivore doesn't fix everything so I
thought because I suffered from such bad
mental illness eating disorders and all
of that has resolved so I thought
carnivore was everything and I also
focus on gut health where if you fix
your mucosal lining you'll strengthen
the barriers and lots of other things
and you can do the probiotics and sure
I've met many of my clients patients
that cannot tolerate probiotics for
various reasons over the years every
single one of my client patients have
challenged me to think otherwise so I
used to think liver was the best thing
to add if you're a nutrient deficient of
your anorexic it's not always the case
and so then I realized that carnivore
doesn't fix everyone it does a lot of
improvement because it's essentially
reducing your overall inflammation
especially when it comes to foods that
your body is intolerant to but I think
if I were to explain stars
um there is a genetic component to it
where basically 20 to 25 percent of the
population so it's about 40 million plus
people have a different genetic wiring
or code from their parents it's on
chromosome six it's called the HLA and
that number based on your genetics again
will
affect how your immune response is to
the outside world whether it's food
whether it's the environment and what
I'm finding is I think when in the
carnivore Community think about how
restrictive in a sense carnivore is
right it's you can only eat meat and
even if you wanted to go to a party and
eat something else you may not be able
to tolerate it that's the people I work
with I work with the same people in the
carnivore community and what I found is
when we do the service testing a lot of
these people have this susceptibility
and then it's activated by the immune
system and I think in the carnivore
Community when you have eaten all meat
for six months to a year and the needle
has not moved enough to Optimal Health
healing if you choose to add other
things you can't add it back that to me
then means that carnivore is becoming a
Band-Aid it's optimal diet but still
there's something else and that's when I
think people should start looking at
environmental toxins and one of them is
related to serves
okay okay
um but does sirs so so what is what is
sirs and and what can trigger it yeah so
serves as a chronic inflammatory
response syndrome and so of that 20 of
the population what happens is we have
two Basics we have two sides to our
immune system one is the um innate
immune side and the one is the Adaptive
and just to make it super simple the
innate is just the initial immune
response it's like the more basic immune
uh function the macrophages just really
simple things and when the Foreigner The
Invader is just less than I it's a lot
more complicated the innate sidewall
then release antigens or Communications
to the Adaptive side of saying hey T
cells B cells memory cells I need you to
come in and remove this toxin because we
can't handle it so the way that it does
that is releasing cytokines it releases
all these immune things to
um communicate and then normally the
Adaptive side will come in and remove it
that 25 20 to 25 of the population
cannot do the trade-off so what ends up
happening is the innate side gets super
inflamed and is saying hey hey there's
this Foreigner or Invader in our system
and I need it to be removed and this
side has no idea and will never know and
so what happens is we get exposed to
these biotoxins it could be water
damaged buildings it could be a recluse
spider bite it could be lime
um lots of things that are natural
toxins
um in our environment and it gets into
our system and the 20 of the population
does not recognize to remove it even
though the innate side sees it and so
what ends up happening is over time it
is not the actual mold itself or the
lime itself it's the inflammatory
response has gone awry and that's the
illness that is the illness and so what
we're trying to do over time with sirs
is essentially we're trying to call that
immune response we're actually we you
can take some binders and it the binder
is very specific but if you take a
certain binder it will actually pull
those toxins that are in your system
that your other side of your immune
system was was not able to remove and
then you can start to find Healing
okay okay that's cool so this isn't just
caused by mold now this could be caused
it could be caused by a virus too or a
bacterial infection initially and any
type of toxin it's mostly from water
damaged buildings and water damaged
buildings can have
um endotoxins biotoxins and actinomyces
it's just a variety of living things
that they could be dead to but
essentially you will it'll trigger that
immune response so I have seen people
with long covid I think they're honestly
suffering from sirs it's just their
immune
system is not able to now turn off that
level of inflammation because again the
other side is not able to recognize it
and shut it off
okay so my
um because I've gone I've done like a
deep dive into mold
I did that a while ago and I know I had
mold exposure when I was about eight but
my symptoms started when I was two I
don't know what happened then so I've
always thought it was viral which is a
you know but I mean
but I mean if something provokes the
immune system and then the immune system
overreacts to everything it wouldn't
really matter what the cause was right
yeah the the thing so there are a lot of
children that show or present serves
these symptoms and it's very very
um light being so if your parents and
maybe you if you have the genetic thing
obviously one of your parents has it if
not both
if they give you like double whammy of
the jeans your chance of being affected
is higher so there are kids
um that that have the HLA and then they
will present even at a young age one of
the biggest symptoms is when your child
is born if they're having Gertie issues
so like they drink a lot of breast milk
or formula and they're always throwing
up so they can't tolerate anything and
then when they're in like Elementary
School these symptoms are they they get
headaches frequently or stomach aches or
they're tired more than the average
child these are the small symptoms and
then it's just over time if the bucket
your toxin bucket load gets filled and
now it starts overflowing that's when
the symptomology becomes really present
and you will start feeling what they
call it a multi-system multi-symptom so
it affects many of your systems in your
body and then it has multiple symptoms
so where I think serves gets really
confusing for people is
um there's a whole process processing
that occurs and it starts affecting your
adrenal function your androgens or your
hormones your sleep your pain and so
people start getting misdiagnosed for so
many different things and people say oh
it's fibromyalgia oh you have chronic
fatigue syndrome
um and the question should always be why
why did that happen what is going on and
I I just saw a number a statistics where
if you get a second diagnosis eighty
percent is usually different and the
study was done by Mayo Clinic so how do
you know that the diagnosis you got is
correct
yeah okay that's very interesting so
then what do you do like how do you how
do you test for it and is this test just
in kind of the integrative Medicine area
or is this also more mainstream so the
in 2008 I believe the usgao accepted
that um sirs is an illness that mold in
your homes from water damage buildings
can make you sick so it is accepted I
believe that when the community at large
or the medical industry at large accepts
mold as a true illness then the
hospitals this is the only peer-reviewed
evidence-based protocol that has over 25
Papers written on it I think it will be
the one that's adopted I know that there
are so many mold protocols online and
it's not getting to the root cause the
root cause is the chronic inflammation
it is that lots of things have happened
the cytokines releasing and affecting
leptin and then leptin receptors are
releasing lots of leptin and causing
some people to be overweight but it's
because they're trying to release a
hormone called melanocyte stimulating
hormone and what ends up happening is it
gets blocked from being produced and
that it's that msh that then affects all
the different Downstream symptoms when
we get sick from this illness we produce
a lot of cortisol and that affects our
brain initially our brain will become I
guess it has a lot more excess cortisol
in the hippocampus than it affects our
hypothalamus and then it affects our
pituitary and at first the again that
innate immune system is trying to tell
the Adaptive side there's a fire we need
to resolve this and cortisol is
obviously that stress response nothing
happens and over time the brain says we
need to shut down we have so much
saturation of cortisol in the
hippocampus and when that shutdown
happens then the the other parts of the
brain start also saying we need to shut
down to protect this body from dying and
when that shutdown happens that's when
that Master hormone the melanocyte
stimulating hormones uh reduces and it's
when that reduction happens that every
Downstream symptomology starts to occur
that's when our hormones get messed up
um Again The Chronic pain lack of sleep
the electrolyte stuff it's really
fascinating but a lot of the reasons why
people say carnivore doesn't work is
actually it's very very related to
possibly sirs I think when people say I
can't balance my electrolytes on
Carnivore yes when we don't eat or
consume a lot of glucose we have less
water retention so what if we are
naturally imbalanced in our electrolytes
no matter how much sodium or
electrolytes we consume we're not
balancing what if that's always an issue
carbs will mask it but it's not
resolving it and one hormone to give you
an example answers when you have the low
msh it affects your antidiuretic hormone
and that ADH is what helps you to hold
on to water and so there's a lot of
carnivores they're constantly thirsty
constantly drinking but the ADH hormone
is low so they just keep peeing it out
so they never feel hydrated so what if
that's the issue and not an electrolyte
imbalance so that they need to add carbs
there's so many examples of this yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah I don't know I know
I totally get that yeah when uh whenever
so my both my parents are like they're
good now okay they're good now but
they're so sick if they're not on this
diet that they would be dead like it's
crazy my mom has lupus and my dad has
like severe depression if he's not on
the diet and amongst other things with
like psoriasis he had gerd so like
there's there's a bunch of things um
going on and my dad
um his reactions are like more severe or
acute they're more acute I would say
when he accidentally eats something so
if he goes to a restaurant he gets hit
with something and he knows that he's
having a reaction because he is
extremely anxious but he gets so thirsty
he'll drink like seven liters of water
like he's just like waking up at night
drinking water and we thought well maybe
it's your body trying to like flush out
whatever's happening like giving you an
allergic reaction but it would be nice
to get like less reactive for them too
right particularly particularly my dad
so the you can do genetic testing to
look for it and then you can do these
blood measurements looking at msh yes
and then what so what was the other line
really quickly with your dad I think um
one big component of serves is mental
illness it's a huge component so a lot
of the markers they become it affects
your blood brain barrier causes it to be
permeable so a lot of people I'll just
give you a few examples of my client
patients a lot of people have been
diagnosed with bipolar they will go to
their doctors and then they'll do all
the blood work on the Adaptive side
which is not the side that this is
affecting and the doctor says your CRP
looks good your insulin is good right
because they're on a carnivore diet
everything's good I think it's in your
head and so they recommend them to a
psychiatrist and they get them on meds
because they are believing or feeling
these fake symptoms and as we test for
serves we realize actually there are
toxins that are getting into your brain
because it's breached from the
blood-brain barrier because of the
certain markers that are inflamed with
all that said the way to the best way to
test is there's a vision test um I would
say that's the most economical way to
start so if you fail this vision test
and it's an it's a contrast sensitivity
test the Air Force is the one that
created this test and what they do and
they still use it now is they want you
to take a simple test to see can you see
contrast and it's really faint it's like
these gray squiggly lines and if your
brain function isn't optimal you will
not see those lines and it's 15 you
could do it online if you have a decent
computer modern electronic so I I'll
give you all the information afterward
but you could take that test if you fail
it there's a 90 chance you are suffering
from sirs and then afterward the other
thing to look at is there's a cluster of
symptoms that most serves people are
suffering with now carnivore will mask
some of them so a lot of people will say
oh I don't suffer from a lot of those
symptoms anymore maybe I only have half
but it's the question is is it because
carnivore is doing so well with that so
that's the other thing to look at if you
fall into eight of the 13 clusters which
are symptomologies you just have to look
at the chart and then you fail the VCS
test the chance of you having service is
98 percent
hmm okay and then you do blood work so
you can go um all the providers we also
do it too but we usually use lab poor
requests and the genetic is um test is
also through the lab work and uh we just
test the inflammatories or the um innate
side of the inflammatory system and not
the adoptive side so so many of my
clients again their immune system looks
wonderful all the markers look great but
then when we test the innate side
there's so much inflammation and so
that's why even if there's questions
with this whole protocol there's
Baseline numbers you can look at there
are numbers that are out of range and
that's why I fell in love with this
because it's not we're guessing or you
do a urine test and they're showing that
there's a release of mold we don't know
if that's a good thing because you're
releasing something that you ate or or
that you're always suffering from it we
just don't know whereas this one there
are numbers hard numbers that we go by
that you do with blood work and then as
you heal you see the numbers go down so
your inflammatory response is reducing
and the whole process is reducing each
each inflammation marker so that things
start settling down you start telling
your immune system hey everything's okay
you don't need to be on uh fight mode
and you could be back in surveillance
mode and once you get there you take the
VIP which that is a polypeptide that
basically helps your hormone system or
that msh to be supporting your body
again so that things normalize you can
take if you want to eat other foods you
should be able to that's the goal the
goal is root cause and being able to
tolerate a lot of other foods for you
and your parents hey this episode was
sponsored by nordvpn as someone who
travels a lot I was always worried about
using public Wi-Fi and exposing my
personal information that's why I turned
to nordvpn no it's not I wrote this ad
with chat GPT is that cheating
that's not why I turned to nordvpn it's
a good reason nordvpn does keep your
personal information safe but I turned
to nordvpn to download movies without
going to jail
now I'm talking about it anyway back to
the ad not only has nordvpn kept my data
secure while I'm on the go which it has
but I've also been able to access
content that might not be available in
my current location that did happen I
used it in Serbia to get to Disney
serbians don't like Disney I don't know
about serbians but the government
doesn't like Disney weird anyway it's
been a game changer for me if you're
looking for a reliable and secure VPN
service which you should just have
turned on on your computer look no
further nordvpn is the best option out
there it's what I use with nordvpn you
can browse the internet safely and
securely no matter where you are and
right now you can grab your exclusive
nordvpn deal by going to nordvpn.com
tmpp
which is the acronym for my podcast to
get a huge discount off your nordvpn
plan plus a bonus gift it's completely
risk-free with nord's 30-day money-back
guarantee and if that wasn't enough
nordvpn also has a free anti-malware
feature to keep your device safe from
any unwanted threats again head to
nordvpn.com tmpp or use promo code tmpp
to get a huge discount off their Premium
plan and take advantage of their free
anti-malware feature and the ability to
access Netflix from different countries
and download movies
okay cool well I will definitely I mean
if it if it's as simple as you can test
it to see it's just strange because for
us like my parents are feeling great
like I'm feeling really good
but I can't like change anything
like things are really good so if you're
like well what are your symptoms what
are my symptoms
um
I don't know like I'm super alert I
think my environmental allergies
they're quite bad they're quite bad they
were always really bad though but they
haven't gotten better
um and then I don't know other than that
I'm just like perma-sensitive so I in
terms of the environmental allergies
immune system this is how I think of it
if you're
bodies
um immune system and it it's not being
affected by other things so let's say
Foods right so plant toxins uh plant
sensitivities then your body should get
stronger so that now it has the ability
and room to deal with the environmental
stuff so if you have seasonal allergies
I used to have seasonal allergies when I
used to be plant-based I have zero
seasonal allergies and yeah and I do I
do badly and I've removed like it's
crazy everything's out of my diet like
everything I never cheat like toxins in
my environment there aren't any because
as soon as there's one I can tell like
so
so then why like my assumption was once
I did that I would heal and then become
less sensitive and it just hasn't
happened it's so strange and that's the
that is what's supposed to happen
ideally your body gets stronger yeah I
mean Coastal lining of everything gets
stronger in your body
um your your cells are nutrient dense
because of the foods you're eating right
so they're all getting the proper
nutrition to break down into raw
materials to support the whole system
when you're dealing with something other
than food that's why it's not happening
and that's where I think carnivore
becomes a Band-Aid and I I mean I am a
carnivore nutritionist I believe in
carnivore it's healed me so much it's
why I don't think the fruit and honey
stuff is ideal but I have to be honest
for my patients and clients of there is
a point where carnivore only works to a
certain point and then you have to look
further I don't think it means that you
have to remove carnivore as a healing
mechanism you may be able to become like
heat of war or a carnivore plus some
plants over time yeah and if but I want
people to get to a place of I choose to
only eat meat not I can only eat meat
it's a huge difference in healing and I
I think there's so many carnivores where
I mean I'll I'll call it there's so many
influencers in the carnivorous space
that say you're not healing it's because
you haven't removed the um the
seasonings or the sweeteners or the
coffee you're not carnivoring harder you
should be adding organs and it's not
that simple or that people should be
removing salt the ADH osmolality affects
your salt so what if removing salt or
adding salt is just a Band-Aid for that
ADH marker it's so simple you just go
and test it right there's so many even
the low testosterone
um two ways that serves affects
testosterone right we hear that so much
in the carnivore community of oh uh this
diet is going to ruin your testosterone
and one if you eat sufficient fat that
should benefit it but
um one thing is so testosterone
um once it comes into the body serves
increases your aromatase enzyme and for
men especially when you are even taking
exogenous hormones or the testosterone
it will convert a lot of the
testosterone to estrogen because of that
aromatase so how do we know that some of
the men are not suffering from sirs
which is then converting their
testosterone to estrogen and it's not
that they're just low on tea because of
the diet there's just so many examples
of that because of sirs
wow okay well that sounds good I mean
what I like about that too is there's
tests you can do to see tests yes yeah
yeah okay amazing great well
yeah and I um and we could talk offline
about the testing stuff but I I have
seen so much healing in some of my
sickest clients and patients where I
thought maybe this is the best they can
be where they graduated from a grade F
of Health to us yeah yeah and now
they're actually close in a I have one
client I just shared her story she was
never able to consume Dairy she had
histamine reactions for anything she ate
she only ate grass-fed she did a lion
diet she improved a lot but then her
symptoms would eventually kind of come
back depending on the environment and
once you started working with me we did
gut supports again it helped a little
bit but not enough until we found sirs
and she's been diagnosed with multiple
sclerosis
um Hashimoto's and she has serves she's
done the whole protocol she's not fully
done yet she's been doing it for nine
months fixing the environment so the
home is safe and not water damaged
she can tolerate any plant she wants she
could do dairy
um she she doesn't have any history
issues she used to take sinus medication
every night to sleep because her nasal
and that is also affected by sirs she
does none of that and she's not even
done with the whole protocol she's not
on that VIP spray yet but she's taking
the binders to remove most of the
biotoxins that have come in our body and
cause inflammation everywhere in our
system
wow wouldn't you assume though and I do
want to move on from yeah I'm sure not
everyone's interested as interested as I
am in this but wouldn't you assume that
if you remove the toxin from your
environment after because I've moved to
like I don't know I've lived in 30
different houses wow and I like I can
usually smell you can like I know that
either can be water damage that you
can't smell but I'm pretty paranoid
about mold so I had mold exposure when I
was young but I'm pretty I've been
pretty careful about my environment it
wouldn't your body after I don't know
five years wouldn't those toxins just go
away naturally so if you if you are part
of that 20 of the genetic susceptibility
it won't go away so it doesn't know how
to remove it because the Adaptive side
and most of the mold that we get sick
from is not the water damage the one
that the active mildewy smell it's when
spores or mold dries up and then it
breaks into fragments and I think one
sport brings into thousands of fragments
and it's those really small bits it's
that can breach the blood-brain barrier
and those are the ones that actually
make us sicker
okay that's gross yeah okay okay moving
on from serve we'll talk offline and I
think what I'll do just so people are
aware is I'll do all the tests and
everything and then do an update to see
if yeah that was I have no like I have
no hope anymore I have this diet the
diet's great it's keeping me in a good
place but like I'd be able I'd like to
be able to eat lettuce again but um I'm
excited for you maybe who knows
um okay so for for other people a couple
of things what happens if you've been
doing carnivore for for a while
uh and you end up with a low vitamin
safe folate I know a lot of people
who've had low Folly and my fall 8
showed up as low I didn't have any
symptoms of low folate but it was low
so yeah what do people do and then
should they be concerned I feel like low
folate isn't ideal right so
you need folate if you're going to make
a baby and obviously folate is just good
um it's obviously one of the essential
vitamins but it may be a new normal so
maybe if the thing is most carnivores
don't test folate because it's not one
of the general tests that are done and
so people will go out of their way to
test their folate um and so the subset
of people that are testing are small but
it could be a normal
um a new normal just like our vitamin C
yeah yeah a new normal or LDL for
example so that's one but if you do want
to supplement um I think I was looking
at a lot of the nutrition it's I find it
so interesting so I know that a lot of
the beef liver community that especially
the desiccated organ supplements um the
the other products out there they tout
that that is the best food to consume
for folate and it's just not true so I
you know because I create a lot of the
graphics and I'm always on USD looking
at the content and
um chicken liver is actually higher in
folate than beef liver so one one ounce
of beef liver has about 20 of your daily
value so in terms of supplements that's
six so in order to get a hundred percent
of your daily value you would need to
take about 30 to 31 supplements of the
those organ supplements which then
there's the risk of hyper vitaminosis a
and copper toxicity whereas chicken
liver I think one ounce has 45 of your
daily value so oh wow if you really want
to supplement and again it we don't know
what the new Norm is if there's no
symptoms the question always is does
that then matter but
um you can consume chicken liver one
ounce again has 40 it's also there is
some folate in lamb and then there's
also folate and egg yolks so that would
be my suggestion some other people again
if there's a root cause if it's that
you're not methylating properly if it's
that your homocysteine is high it might
just be that you need a little support
with the methylated B and I interviewed
someone not too long ago and they said
that their patients consume the folate
from supplements from these organ
supplements and they don't see the
needle move enough until they actually
take a methylated b
okay
yeah okay that's interesting
okay okay
um
okay histamine histamine intolerance on
Carnivore how often do you see that and
do you know why that happens yeah so
um
histamines are often thought of being
released by MCAS and MCAS is basically a
immune system response to protect your
body when it comes to sirs it's not that
it's a histamine response is part of
that innate immune side and so there are
I think like 200 chemical mediators that
your immune system releases to notify
the body that there's something inside
your body that's not supposed to be
there one of the responses is a
histamine response so if you're
suffering from sirs that histamine
response is actually a gene activation
it's not related to MCAS now when you
consume meats and foods that have less
histamines you'll feel less of a symptom
but it's not because
um of the food itself that's making you
have a histamine response I hear it all
the time carnivore made my histamines
get worse it's not though it's actually
that maybe your Gene activation is now
more present and you're noticing it more
compared to when you're eating all these
plant-based foods that were inundating
your body with so much inflammation that
you didn't know what was up from down
yeah okay interesting very interesting
what about
um let me see
okay what about people who introduce raw
milk how do you feel about raw milk yeah
so my boys are on they've been drinking
raw milk forever
um I'm a fan of it it really depends on
you so if for example any amount of
sugars will affect your blood sugar your
insulin levels if you're metabolically
on well maybe it's not ideal for you if
a little bit of sugar then triggers you
to want to binge probably not ideal for
you
um I know that it's good for gut health
but then if you're really really
permeable with gut health it may not
still be good just because of the
lactose so it really depends I would say
for your individual body just maybe try
an ounce a day see how you feel with
your normal Baseline of Health if you
start feeling reactions it might not be
good but you want to do that for about
three to five days the only thing you're
introducing is little bits of raw milk
and that's how to ideally know if raw
milk is benefiting you or not
seems like a good idea yeah and then and
then what about probiotics how do you
feel about probiotics so I'm a fan of
probiotics I think that so much of our
world and antibiotic use and the die off
of some of the chemicals and pesticides
we use in a lot of our plant-based foods
are riddled with the pesticide
glyphosate Etc and so it's beneficial
but from my sickest clients they cannot
tolerate probiotics at first even if I
tell them to open the capsule and take a
little bit it affects them and I think
it's because their immune system is so
heightened that any bit whether it's
good or bad is going to affect them so
once you get to a place that you can
tolerate them I highly recommend a high
quality one if you're eating carnivore
and long term you're doing good maybe
you do once a year for maintenance but I
think if you're coming from a standard
American diet you've been on antibiotics
you've been you were born C-section you
didn't get breastfed
for those people it may be beneficial
just do a dose but once you're on
Carnivore long term I think maybe once a
year once every two years but if you're
not able to tolerate it there's another
root cause
yeah I like this
this is then this is what I've been
thinking too it's like obviously there's
something going on it's just what is it
and what if it's a viral infection
that's like in my cells
and it's just there that would be worst
case scenario have you ever had sir um
have you ever had covet
oh my gosh yeah I've had covet four
times oh my gosh okay so I I
I think a new strand comes out you get
it yeah okay so I I don't know if it's a
viral infection now the testing will
determine it one thing that a lot of the
service providers says is don't try to
say that a certain symptom is therefore
equals this so for example a lot of the
people in the line Community will say if
you have babicia your symptoms are more
this versus if it's just Lyme and it's
your immune system works together so
every person will manifest the symptoms
differently so it's really hard to say
this equals that and it's more you could
just get tested that's the easiest way
to know is your inflammatory responses
system on the innate side heightened and
then what can we do to just reduce every
single inflammatory marker and that's
the goal
that's cool and are the binders you take
for this to remove toxins or those
prescription or these supplements yeah
they're prescription so it's actually
used for cholesterol reduction so that's
where I think Carnivor is perfect if
you've been eating high fat your
cholesterol is probably high anyway yeah
and so just for a short period of time
you take these cholesterol reducers it's
not statins it's a binder and
um when you take it it will REM because
it's the same charge and the same size
of these biotoxins in your system it's
why some of the other like activated
charcoal and all these other supplement
types of binders don't work as well
they're the wrong charge wrong size and
it doesn't fit perfectly that's why this
medicated version is ideal and if you
don't tolerate as well in the beginning
it could be your either your immune
system is really high but there's ways
to work around that but it's a that
cholesterol reducing medication which we
use for sirs to actually pull the binder
and remove some of the the yucky stuff
that's in the bile
cool yeah okay
cool I tried um chlora like early on
five five years ago yeah like everything
bentonite clay activated charcoal
Chlorella
yeah it was just like nothing I know I
mean activated charcoal like at least it
didn't do anything bad and I don't think
bentonite clay did anything bad Corella
didn't make me feel good
um but just like nothing nothing was
useful until this diet at all yeah and
I've never taken a supplement that's
helped at all except for this new enzyme
which is just like magical I cannot
believe how well that works for
histamine intolerance and then it helps
to break down histamines and that's
that's why because if you have yeah
assumption it'll produce more Dao in
this um the gut
no I know I was trying to explain that
to my mom too because she's like maybe
we have a genetic problem but I ran our
like I we did 23andMe in like 2013 I got
my entire family to do it and it doesn't
look like we have a genetic
susceptibility to histamine and
tolerance I was like I think it's just a
gut thing I think it's a gene thing for
you
I don't know okay we'll see we'll have
to see I think this is what I think of
toxins so we all have a toxin bucket
this is the example I always give my
clients what as you're growing up
everything it'll keep loading and
loading and eventually the bucket will
overflow and once it overflows that's
when you feel the symptomology so as
when you're young you may not feel as
much you might have the small like
little headaches the tiredness because
of the genetic susceptibility but over
time if this bucket is fully full you
will start feeling sick I think why some
of those other binders the supplements
the more natural forms are beneficial is
it will reduce a little bit of this and
so some people may be reducing the heavy
metal load or some other toxin that's in
their system and they'll say oh my gosh
I feel a little better but if three
months later you're starting to feel
sick again it's not the answer and
that's really what I want to press is
even with carnivore it absolutely
reduces inflammation it's one of the
papers I'm trying to write of how mmp9
and carnivore itself uh helps to reduce
inflammation and why people fare better
on sirs with carnivore because it
reduces the overall inflammation load
but not enough and so I think with
carnivore it reduces a lot of this but
the question should always be what is
making my load full anyway right of what
is making it that I can't even tolerate
a little bit of vegetables or a little
bit of something that most other people
can and that's what what I always mean
by getting super cause
yeah cool yeah okay how do you feel
about how do you feel about honey and
fruit
the doctors that are like I eat yeah but
I'm also a carnivore so I always wonder
the question is always why so if you can
tolerate it you're metabolically
flexible
um you are an athlete and you feel
better on it and all your symptoms are
as good as Baseline then maybe it's not
an issue if you are metabolically
flexible again
one thing that concerns me with fruit
and honey is a lot of people that come
to this way of eating they have they
struggle with obesity or they have
insulin resistance for those people
something like
um a fruit can become a pie right so
apples become apple pie and so they
start binging I have clients they do
intake forms and they tell me I tried
the fruit and honey because I wasn't
feeling well and now six months out I'm
struggling and I'm on the standard
American diet so I'm trying to work with
you to get back on that's the concern of
it and then the other thing is with when
it comes to sirs there is one
inflammatory marker that gets
exacerbated when you eat more sugar so
um sugar can be inflammatory and there's
a marker called mmp9 when and when you
eat a higher carb diet that marker will
go up and what we're seeing and this is
the paper we're trying to write is that
mmp9 is actually lower on all meat
carnivore so again it may be the
Band-Aid to hold enough water so you
don't feel the electrolyte issues but is
it really resolving the root cause issue
so that's that and then honey is we're
all afraid of high fructose corn syrup
we know it's bad I know that honey has
some types of benefits
um I did research when I was writing my
first book honey a lot of times is not
being
um regulated and so sometimes they might
add more color to make it look more
ambery um it's just not regulated you
don't know if you're getting a little
bit of high fructose corn syrup and
honey itself is very high in fructose
and it and there are some people
researchers that say fructose is what is
really making us sick and fat and unwell
and if we know that high fructose corn
syrup is not ideal then why are we
consuming honey that has actually a
little bit more fructose proportionally
than high fructose corn syrup
that's fair I seem to I seem to be able
to eat honey a little bit okay like
that's the only thing
I can do without having an inflammatory
reaction
which is strange I would have thought
the like pollen in it
would have bothered you yeah but it
would yeah
it'll be interesting to test your mmp9
because that gets affected if there's a
little bit more sugar it's not always
like that but it'll be interesting to
see that and that's just another blood
test you can take and just take yeah
it's part of the sirs blood work is like
this one package yeah it's cool okay
great I'm definitely gonna do that and I
will update everybody to see see what
happens that's fun
okay what else I had I had the community
ask some questions too I answered like
one of them like the low folate question
um what about
what time is it okay a few more
um okay and then so how do you feel
about like calcium levels and iodine are
those important to supplement or do you
not need to supplement those people
talked about iodine I never I never
supplemented iodine I don't even know
what the body needs iodine for to be
honest but people talk about it yeah
yeah so I I do recommend supplementing
iodine and oh okay so and the reason is
so a lot of people think that taking
iodized salt which is just table salt
has iodine so that's sufficient the
reason the government put that in is
because people were having goiters that
um because they were insufficient in
iodine and so that's why they created
iodized salt there's so many studies
that show that the iodized salt does not
have enough iodine because some of it
gets evaporated in the air as they're
processing it there's also a lot of junk
in iodized salt so it's not ideal for
that reasons too
um there's a lot of other countries that
are suffering from goiters and other
illnesses based off low iodine so it's
just something to consider every cell
uses iodine
um are the main part of our body that
really uses eye done also is thyroid so
you need proteins as well as iodine to
then produce thyroid so in my practice
if someone is having issues with thyroid
markers I will always recommend them to
take a little bit of iodine and you just
use the iodine drops and for some people
that also suffer from I don't know I
wouldn't say a genetic component of
breast cancer but I had somebody on my
channel where they talked about they've
done so much research where the increase
in breast cancer is actually because of
a deficiency in iodine I haven't looked
into it as much but there's no harm in
doing uh supplementing with iodine
there's old research that says if you
use iodine especially if you're
hypothyroid it'll exacerbate that that
was with radioactive iodine it is not
the same as what we're supplementing
with there's a test you could take you
take 50 milligrams of iodine which is a
lot and you pee it out and so that's the
way the body works with excess iodine
you just remove it if you're struggling
with bromide and fluoride they're all
part of the same table of elements if
you take take the iodine it'll flush out
some of that as well so I think it's
ideal if someone can people can even
take a little bit and one of the
benefits I hear from my clients is
you'll feel like more tenderness and
breast fullness in your breasts when you
take iodine and then for some people in
the morning they'll feel more energy
especially if you're hypothyroid
huh that's cool and there's no downsides
um no I know again there's research
where people will say no no there's
thyroid doctors that say it's so bad for
you but again if you look at the
literature it's because it was
radioactive iodine it's not the same
okay cool yeah okay what about what
about calcium so calcium is normally
people are not deficient because of
calcium itself it's all the cofactor so
in order for calcium to go to the right
places it really depends depends on a
lot of the cofactors if you're eating
sufficient meat
um your stress levels are reduced when
you're stressed you will bleed out more
calcium so it's not a I'm not eating
sufficient calcium I know people get
worried well I don't eat fish I don't
eat fish with bones and then I don't eat
dairy so where am I getting my calcium
normally it's not the calcium itself if
you need calcium you can always
supplement but typically speaking um
it's usually like the cofactor vitamin D
or magnesium or high stress in the life
of
um too much cortisol for example so I
would look into a little bit of the
cofactors of calcium make sure that that
is all sufficient and then you can and
then if it's still imbalance that's when
you can then consider calcium there's a
lot of studies that show I think it's
like mid-age women they supplement
calcium and then they have higher risk
of heart disease so I normally don't
recommend calcium right away
okay that's good to know
that's because you know okay vitamin D
um
is low vitamin D another sign of sirs
yes
um so it's not in the literature so I
have to always preface that
um I have seen so I get very iffy about
vitamin D because a lot of the vitamin D
I think they use certain ingredients
that are similar to rat poison I know
vitamin D has been super highly
advocated for during covid so I am a
little bit more cautious about it and
I've been a little bit less vocal about
it there might be incorrect numbers that
we are chasing for vitamin D levels
that's one and I I could share a study
with you I'll give it to you afterward
but it says that actually the optimal
levels like 25 and that people were
reading the paper wrong
I haven't looked into it enough to say
yay or nay what I have seen is a lot of
my clients again they're the sickest of
the carnivore Community their vitamin D
is low so a lot of them will do the D3
K2 5000 10 000 IUS it barely moves the
needle barely moves yeah when they go
through the source protocol they take
the VIP there has been a strong
association with when the VIP regulates
the msh goes up and all the symptoms
start reducing their vitamin D goes up
naturally
hmm cool yeah
okay well this sounds this sounds
interesting have you done any research
looking into stem cell infusions for
autoimmunity or NK cell infusions
um not you
not a ton um I know that it's an option
so when people are unwell the stem cells
can maybe
regenerate things or make things better
in the system I just I'm all for all of
these things I know that some people use
adjunct therapies with carnivore and I'm
supportive of all of them even if you
use CBD at night melatonin I mean
melatonin is kind of a hormone so I'm
just a little iffy with that that's also
affected by sirs I always say get to
root cause so why do you need the stem
cells right if you think about a couple
hundred years ago no one needed that if
you want to use it to have longevity and
live longer and healthier maybe but if
you're doing it because you're not
unwell then figure out what's making you
unwell first and then if you want to use
it totally supportive
yeah okay okay great okay let me see
what else do I have here okay so say
you've done carnivore for a while say
you've done a meat only diet like the
lion diet for a while and you're trying
to reintroduce Foods how do you suggest
people reintroduce Foods I always say
look at your symptomology so if you came
to this way of eating and you had
diabetes maybe fruit is the last one you
want to reintroduce if you struggled
with gut issues maybe foods with lectins
are the last one you want to reduce
reintroduce so it really depends on your
current situation of why you went to
carnivore and then maybe not picking the
certain foods that have certain
anti-nutrients so that's the first thing
but once you decide okay I'm going to
add leafy greens or add some berries
always start like I mentioned about the
um the raw milk start with your Baseline
and I always measure a few markers for
health it's your sleep your mood your
energies your stool and your hormones
and so have that Baseline of Health if
you want to do blood work you can but
otherwise just go by symptomologies and
then use a food and mood Journal write
down everything that you're noticing and
if you let's say want to introduce
berries maybe start with half a cup at
lunch and just do one serving and that's
it that's the only difference of um what
you're currently eating and then write
down how you feel how do you feel after
an hour how's your mood how's your stool
um how's your sleep and then the next
day maybe you do half a cup at lunch and
then half a cup at dinner and then do
the same thing and I know it's so
cumbersome but that's the best way to
know more than any IGG test many um any
food sensitivity test if you haven't
consumed gluten in forever your IGG test
is not going to pick that up right so
the best way is listening and honoring
your body's reactions and so after three
to five days of using the same food and
then increasing its dose message if you
are feeling fine then that food is
probably
um safe for you and then you keep doing
that with every food you want to
reintroduce and if you have a bad
reaction you want to go back to Baseline
by eating just the Baseline Foods you
ate wait for that symptomology to go
down back to your Baseline and then
start with a different food and you know
that current food was not the food to
reintroduced First
yeah it's so hard for me to understand
how this isn't just widely known in the
medical industry it's like
duh you can eat one thing you can get
your inflammation levels down yeah track
your food introduce one by one and see
what happens there you go that's such a
it's like an elevator pitch it's not a
complicated idea I don't know why like
everybody should try that I think part
of the reason is we live in a society of
I want results now right give me a pill
give me something instead of doing a
carnivore diet which sounds so crazy but
if you have this crazy healing you know
how powerful it is and I think to say oh
my gosh so if I want to introduce I
don't know um if there's 365 days it
would take you like a hundred it would
take a full year to introduce just 100
foods and so for some people that's just
too much just give me an idg test or a
food allergy test and just tell me what
I'm allergic to and I just won't eat
those it's easier but it's not the right
answer because your body's mechanisms
and symptoms are the strongest way to
know if something is working or it's not
yeah also like regarding those IGG tests
they were pretty accurate for me when I
was eating you know when everything was
in my diet sure the things that showed
up in like red and orange they made me
very ill when I tried to reintroduce
them but there were some things I was
very sensitive to that didn't show up so
okay not everything like you know gives
you an IGG response so so those tests
don't work the same way as reintroducing
Foods reintroducing Foods is like a sure
way to do it yeah your body makes sense
never has symptoms and if it does have
symptoms it's telling you that
something's off so when people
supplement hormones or something and
they say I'm I'm low I took a Dutch test
and I found that I'm low in estrogen so
I should start supplementing estrogen or
when they start supplement with
progesterone you have to find out why
you're low because your body will do the
best they can with what it has and when
it's not when you don't have enough or
things aren't working well enough it
will show it in symptomologies and when
we just say it's that whole medical
staff standard of oh if you're low in
progesterone just supplement with
progesterone and that works a little bit
but then some of it if there was an
imbalance already it's going to go to
that imbalance too so sometimes
progesterone gets shuttled to make
cortisol and cortisol is a catabolic
hormone meaning it breaks down tissue
and stuff so if you're supplementing
progesterone some of it will go to
Progesterone but some of it's going to
go and produce more cortisol so the goal
is to actually figure out why you're low
in progesterone and I think that's where
doing a food and mood journal and eating
the foods and seeing your own bodily
reaction your body's saying no I don't
like that or yes I do and if you can't
um
if you can't consume anything beyond
meat then it becomes a Band-Aid
especially if you've been doing it long
term because your body should have been
healing so much to then reintroduce
other things and if you can't dig deeper
definitely
um how do you suggest people start the
carnivore diet if they're on a standard
American diet do you ever say people
just you know Jump Right In you're gonna
suffer a little bit but jump in or do
you have a weaning process
I think it depends on the person again I
know sorry I don't give like these
straight answers but because I think it
really is individualized yeah if you are
an abstainer versus moderator so that
really means if you're all or nothing if
you notice that you have addictions or
habitudes where either you can eat one
cookie and then you don't eat anymore
that's probably where you're a moderator
um if you're an epsteiner it's you try
not to eat the cookie but then once you
eat the cookie you end up eating the
whole box these are the different
personality types and if you know you're
more of an abstainer it's probably
better to go all in and I know it's
tough because you'll go through the keto
flu and just they switch from eating
carbs and being a sugar burner to eating
um meat and then becoming a fat burner
but if you're an abstainer whittling
down the carbs is going to be torturous
for you because every single day you'll
think I can only eat 50 grams today what
does that mean can I eat junky carbs or
can I eat whole food carbs but if you
don't have that personality and you're
more of a moderator the less impact on
the body would be to slowly wean down
the carbs but I don't know many people
that I can honestly do that
yeah okay
okay
if anybody wants to follow you online
where can you direct them yeah so I'm
kind of an Instagram jail I shared a few
things and I think I got in trouble so
it's just FYI but um so you can follow
me on Instagram and YouTube Facebook um
it's all really under nutrition with
Judy and then my book is carnivore cure
so both websites are available and you
can work with us through nutrition with
Judy
cool well thank you very much and we
will talk and I'll do your tests and
we'll see what shows up yeah I'm I'm
super excited for you
I think that everyone deserves a life
symptom-free and live the life that you
are meant to live and if you have
symptoms you'll never be able to do that
I work with so many people that if they
eat something wrong they're bedridden
and I don't just like I got a second
chance with an all-meat carnivore diet I
really believe that everyone needs and
should have the right to live a life
symptom-free and if carnivore is not
giving you that freedom dig a Little
Deeper it's not that the diet's wrong
it's just that you might have something
else additional to food
uh-huh yeah I want you to get tested I I
think I'll definitely do it it's great
like it's crazy I should be
I mean I did like
I know I literally my assumption was I
was just going to get less sensitive and
I went through a ton of stress over the
last number of years which I'm sure
didn't help but like
even the environmental component like I
drive through a neighborhood that has
trees that are blooming and I get brain
fog and do me and it's like that's
excessive right no I agree I think
I would be shocked if you didn't have
sirs um I yeah let's get you tested
um and then we can just go from there
and if you have the genetic thing and
the markers will show if they're in
Balance it's not like I'm saying it's in
Balance yeah the lab core ranges will
show that you're in Balance so I'll give
you all that and
my real thing is if you heal with this
you can help so many people heal that
don't realize
no I know and that's like part of the
reason I'm still looking and have been
looking is because there's so many
people that follow me and I'm like the
idea with the diet is you use this and
then you reintroduce foods and there's
so many people can't read especially
people who gravitate towards a lion diet
those are the people that do that diet
that can't reintroduce foods and it's
like wow something's obviously wrong you
should be able to and I don't know when
it is so ideally at some point I figure
out what it is hopefully it's this we'll
see I just I don't remember like mold I
don't know if mold but I mean let's do
the tests for sure yeah yeah so we it it
might not be just because of mold it
could have been
um exposure to something I mean have you
ever had a flood in the home I mean you
said you had mold um exposure right so
that that can affect you absolutely
so I mean let's just test um I I would
do the vision test I'll email you the
link and just do that if you fail it
there's a higher chance that you have
serves and then the blood work will come
back and then you'll know and then from
there
um you do have to test your home the one
thing um so you moved to Florida
recently
yeah but I mean like I said I've moved
up to 30 different houses okay okay yeah
so it could have been any of that
yeah but Florida has um issues so
there's a lot of my clients that are
from Florida and it's because the red
tide something about the water the fish
there's red tide there's certain points
if you live in Florida long enough
you'll see headlines of don't eat the
fish in the water because there's red
algae bloom red too and those things
it can be a biotoxin in your system and
even if you're just near the ocean and
let's say that's going on where there's
this whole if you just look up news
headlines um there was one I think two
years ago it was really massive in
Florida and then if you breathe that in
um it will further that biotoxin illness
so that's another thing just to consider
um yeah I'm excited to get you tested
and then if you're positive you should
test your parents because your parents
will likely I mean that's the only way
you got it too then and this illness
manifests differently
um it for some people it's mental
illness and then for some people it's
just physical breakdown and some people
it's both so it just really depends and
I mean there's this treatment I mean you
take the binder and in a month you
should notice changes
yeah okay well then that's easy yeah
let's do this when my mom has the like
physical breakdown my dad has the mental
heart and I have both I wonder if she
got both of their jeans yeah probably
and my brother doesn't have either of
them he has no symptoms at all
no what that's crazy I know isn't that
weird it's so crazy he is super blessed
yeah so let's do that and then and then
once you start healing
um you know I think
um yeah I hope that you share so that um
and it's not even about definitely yeah
no no no no no definitely definitely so
let's help I don't know something shows
up it'd be a miracle my hopes are not
very high but I'm definitely willing to
test it's not a miracle I if you are
faith-based um I I really feel I think
God put me here to share about this I
didn't understand how I ran into the
service thing one of my clients was
really sick with mold they did the micro
talks in the p-test and everything was
wrong and I was just figuring out what
protocol do I put her on and I ran into
sirs and I just didn't understand I feel
that I realized carnivore a lot of
people are suffering from sirs and then
it just annoys me that so many people
online are like carnivore harder and
it's not always the answer I think for
people that are really sick they do need
to eat just super clean line diet I I
believe that but for other people there
there's just you know like oh just add a
stick of butter or something else and
it's normally not the answer so yeah I
think we can help a lot of people and if
enough people make a stink they could
fix the building codes that are making
us sick it's the building codes where
they're using paper for um the walls and
then when we have a little bit of water
damage 48 hours in there's almost
guaranteed mold and that's based on the
FEMA recommendations
[Music]
thank you